Um, so Hollywood, I moved to France. Do you understand me?
I moved next to Johnny Depp in France. Um, your boys,
Hollywood man, people that think Hollywood is bad.
People think Hollywood is evil, bro, whatever you think that is.
That's what I am.
It's so annoying when people say that people think something extra is going on
in Hollywood.
It's so annoying how dumb people are when people think something extra is going
on in Hollywood. Like how it's like,
uh, Oh, well, you know that there's a, uh,
a ring of pedophilia that people, Oh really? Dude. Oh,
there's a ring of pedophilia that,
that top producers know about and confide in each other in and keep
kids and pass them around and them over.
Oh yeah. Or are you just bored and sitting down a lot?
Ah.
Dude, there's no pizza gate, man.
People think Hollywood, well, you know,
they got into Hollywood so they could kids. You know that, right.
People look in your eyes and say that and you'll be like, Oh really?
Or do they just produce bad boys, dude,
do you know how bored you have? Look, let me tell you something, man.
And I'm not even will Smith level. I'm not stupid Spielberg's level. You know?
I mean, but dude,
if there was some extra going on, I'd have heard of it.
I'm telling you right now. Cause this is your trusted news news news source.
If you want shots, you come to congratulations.
Calore but if you want trusted news, NPR,
you come to your boy and I will set you straight, dude.
There's nothing going on in Hollywood except for, and action.
That's all that's happened. Sure. Every now and then there's a Harvey Weinstein.
You understand every now and then there's a Harvard Weinstein.
Okay. Every now and then, but that's just like in real life, in real life,
sometimes there's bad guys, but anytime it's Kevin Spacey pops up.
Well, you know,
he was in an and you know Dave and you know this and that happened and you know
that.
It's what happened and this guy was in on it and that's why they made this movie
so they could.
No. Oh.
No, it was Kevin Spacey probably. Did he pick the part in 21?
Because he was around nine, 20 year olds and he could maybe plug one in him.
Yeah. But does that mean there's a pedophilia ring going on?
Does that mean that pizza gate exists in DC? No, dude.
You're just bored and you're sitting down too much. Stand up, go for a run.
You'll realize there's no pizza gate.
I mean insane. This, this, this
notion of, we don't really know what's going on. First of all,
let me say this. Yeah, you do. And second of all,
you, shouldn't
the stuff you don't know is this stuff you shouldn't know now
pull your dirty wife beater down.
It's too high over your belly button. Because dude, if you believe in that,
you are out to lunch. What are you doing? What does that say?
Why are you bringing the sandwich? Oh, cause I'm going out to lunch, dude.
You're an insane person.
Everything that's going on is pretty much everything that's going on.
And I don't want to know, Oh,
you're going to let the government know like Google is starting to attract
people now because of the COVID-19 and some people are like, well,
they shouldn't track us. That's the government.
They shouldn't know what the we're doing at all times. Dude, go ahead,
government. I'll write a list for you about where the I go.
I don't give a where to go. Where am I? My house,
the comedy store. Even in non COVID, 19 related times.
My where even if I go to the strip club, who gives a, you think,
dude say you're cheating on your wife and Google is tracking your
whereabouts. You think they're going to alert your wife, man.
You think the government gives a what you do with your dirty nub.
Just relax, max and stop. Sit and go for a jog. Dude,
go swimming for sake. Wash your hair.
Prob pizza. I hate the name of all names like pizza. Oh,
you know? Cause Joe Biden and Hillary Clinton and they were all Oh yeah.
Oh yeah dude. Oh yeah. Hillary Clinton.
W w w w w had a basement in a pizza shop and was
nine-year-olds. Oh yeah.
The only female that actually nine year olds is the
one that ran for president last time.
Or do you need to go swimming?
Which one is it? Dude? What's more likely
Hillary Clinton's a nine-year-old or you need to get dry or you're too
dry. it up. It's all good, dude. It doesn't,
it doesn't matter, man. You know, it doesn't matter. It's all good. Okay.
But that's the point is that there's not some people who think that there's some
extra going on, dude. You just, you should have lived out your dream.
You should have tried a little harder or something. I get it. It's boring.
You're sitting behind a desk at, uh, at, uh,
bank of America and you Google too much.
Yeah. When really what you want it to be was a rock climber.
But instead you came in a woman when you were 19 and you got a eight year old
now and you can't climb rocks.
So instead you're Googling something behind a desk,
but don't blame your non dream on Hillary
Clinton bucket. And nine-year-old at the bottom of a pizza place in DC.
Do you understand the understand?
Life's just boring. We want excitement,
but it's just boring and that's honestly
awesome.
And if the government is doing something like tracking
us or listening in to my five, people are like, can't trust five G man.
That'll give you, give it to me, man. Hey, Hey 5g,
come comma, come at, come on, 5g. Let's go.
I can't believe it, man.
I can't believe that people will sit there and well you don't, you know,
you know, anytime you talk to a guidance, well, you know,
Y anytime you're talking to a guy and he's like, well, you know why,
you know why? Yeah. I already know why I don't say it. I get it gets cool.
I got buddies that think this, I got bodies that I hang with,
that I like that I have similarities with and,
uh, uh, things that we, what do we call it?
Um, what do you call it?
things that you have in common. I have things in common with like,
I couldn't remember the word comment, dude. Great, cool.
5g is getting to me and um, and they'll say like, well, you know that the
virus, the coat, I mean, you know this right? The COVID-19 virus,
it's manmade that they did it. The, the, the, uh, the military in USA did it.
And they, and they released it in and boom, you know that right?
And they're acting like I'm the. And to that guy, I just go like this. Oh yeah.
Because you know why that guy,
12 years ago his brain went like this.
It started leaking blood. And there's nothing I can do about that. Excuse me.
But is this minority report? Can I go back in time or time cop,
whatever the that movie was, am I,
is Jean-Claude van Damme in time cop? I can't fix his brain.
I can't be like when the guy says, well, you know, whether they do, you know,
you know why, right. You know why, you know what the virus really is.
I can't go like this, hold on one second.
I will meet you 12 years ago and then go back and they'd be like, Hey buddy,
come here and ride when his brain's about to break and just tell him what he
needs to hear. So it doesn't go and then come back and then be like, no,
a lot of were you saying? And they say nothing. Uh, it was from,
it was from a bat and I go like this. Yes,
son-of-a-bitch it was.